[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez voici les titres de ce lundi
25 mai premier conseil installé les élus
désignés dès le premier tour des
municipales le 15 mars dernier se
réunissent en ce moment ils doivent
choisir leurs maires et adjoints samedi
des séances se sont notamment déroulés à
montigny le bretonneux et maurepas
reportage certaines ont dû stopper leur
activité d'autres ont continué leur
action humanitaire les associations se
sont adaptés pendant la crise sanitaire
comment font elles face à cette période
à saint quentin en yvelines
interview et puis il a fait le plein ce
week-end de l'ascension le zoo de thoiry
a rouvert sa partie safari nombreux
étaient les véhicules pour cette
escapade champêtre un compagnie des
animaux du site de semaine exactement
que le déconfinement a débuté en france
et dans les yvelines où 477 personnes
sont décédées du coronavirus dans les
hôpitaux est pour le moment pas
d'augmentation significative du nombre
de personnes hospitalisées dans le
département les chiffres sont même
restés stables durant le week-end six
ans aux patients sont hospitalisés sur
le territoire 40 en réanimation soit un
cas en moins depuis vendredi
1834 personnes sont désormais guéri de
l'aacc ovide 19 est revenu à domicile
dix semaines après le premier tour des
municipales le gouvernement a fixé les
conseils d'installation pour environ
30000 commune entre le 22 et le 28 mai
dans les yvelines plus de 200 sont
concernés les élus se réunissent en ce
moment pour désigner leurs maires et
adjoints c'était le cas samedi à
montigny le bretonneux ou le premier
conseil municipal a installé un nouveau
maire les précisions de mathilde demi
ils se sont quittés le soir du 15 mars
et il se retrouve masqué pour le conseil
d'installation présidée par le doyen
pierre déjean le conseil municipal qui
se déroule à la ferme du manet à voter
pour choisir le nouveau maire et les
adjoints de montigny le bretonneux la
séance va être ouverte va y avoir un
secrétaire option moi je vais te désigné
président
au bénéfice de l'âge et puis je vais
mener l'élection du maire et une fois
qu'il sera élu bien écoutez je retombe à
ma place c'est lui prendra la sienne
mais avec le titre de maire moi je ne
suis que président de séance avec 33
voix pour l'ancien directeur de cabinet
de jean luc rigaut cinq voix pour son
opposante karolinska haut de la liste
m et un vote blanc laura merker devient
le nouveau maire de montigny le
bretonneux
nous avons dans le cadre de ce trop du
programme de la campagne déclinée un
certain nombre d'items sur l'écologie la
sécurité sur la rénovation de l'hyper
centre
nous avons aussi les jeux olympiques
donc tout cela évidemment reste notre
préoccupation et en même temps nous
allons aussi faire avec ce qui vient de
se passer parce qu'on ne peut pas faire
comme si rien ne s'était passé
et tout cela aura forcément des
conséquences négatives et sans doute
positive aussi je pense à la façon dont
les gens se sont organisés les réseaux
d'entre elles qui se sont mises en place
et sur lesquelles il faudra que nos
capitales ision aussi donc nous allons
travailler sur tous ces aspects pour la
liste d'opposition m
cinq sièges ont été obtenues vivien gasc
conseiller municipal d'opposition digère
encore la défaite mais se prépare déjà
pour les prochains conseils municipaux
après notre objectif c'est de rester
dans tous les esprits dans l'esprit de
la campagne et à une opposition
constructive qui vient faire des
propositions qui en alerte en vigie
évidemment sur tous les projets qui sont
portées par les municipalités
mais qui va pousser montigny à être
toujours plus en avant sur sur les
questions écologiques notamment et de la
démocratie
participation l'équipe municipale se
rassemblera le 2 et 22 juin prochain
pour les conseils municipaux
le budget de la commune sera notamment
voter à ces dates même exercice pour la
ville de maurepas qui organisait ce
samedi également son conseil
d'installation pour respecter les
mesures de protection pendant le conseil
le gymnase de la malle me donne a été
réquisitionnée et grégory cariste y ait
donc été élu pour un deuxième mandat
comme maire de maurepas de nouveaux
matile de 2 min
les tables sont espacées d'un mètre
entre chaque conseillers municipaux le
gel hydroalcoolique et les masques sont
de rigueur pour ce conseil
d'installation qui se déroulent au
gymnase de la malle me donne à maurepas
on est dans un lieu qui est beaucoup
plus ventilé ce qui permet aussi de
respecter les distanciation entre chaque
élu est ce qu'il va nous permettre
évidemment d'installer correctement le
conseil municipal d'élire le maire ses
adjoints et de commencer à travailler
le conseil a voté grégory gare et astier
est élu pour un deuxième mandat à
maurepas
difficile de respecter les gestes
barrière au moment de passer l'écharpé
tricolore
il est à présent l'heure pour le maire
de mort pas de se concentrer avec ses
nouveaux adjoints et conseillers
municipaux sur les projets lancés lors
de son premier mandat
le réaménagement du carrefour de la
malle me donne ou encore la construction
du centre aquatique seront au coeur des
discussions des renouveler plus de 50%
de mon équipe et donc c'est important
aussi pour un maire de jalhay dire
d'être sur deux jambes une jambe de
l'expérience et l'autre jambe du
renouvellement du renouveau pour
stimuler aussi la créativité et peut
aussi continuer à développer de nouveaux
projets donc en tout cas je suis très
satisfait de n'avoir pu être élu dès le
premier tour grâce au mort passe bien
pour qu'on puisse justement continuer de
faire en sorte que me repasse une belle
ville équilibrée protéger dans son
caractère rural et en même temps
modernes avec des projets que nous avons
lancé depuis 2014 et qui vont continuer
parmi les groupes d'opposition la liste
maurepas dynamique et solidaire arrivé
3e au scrutin obtient 3 sièges au
conseil municipal
c'est un conseil d'installation donc que
ce sera pas un conseil politique
il s'agit de nommer le maire de nommer
les adjoints c'est essentiellement le
sujet en fait aujourd'hui des
délibérations et ensuite l'aspect
politique deviendra par la suite mais
évidemment il faut que cette
installation soit fait pour que la vie
municipale puisse reprendre son long
chemin naturel traditionnel une autre
liste d'opposition ensemble en avant
maurepas a déposé pendant le confinement
un recours pour contester des élections
au conseil d'état et pour précisions
d'autres conseils municipaux
d'installation auront lieu cette semaine
si on place le curseur à 50 ans new line
notamment ce soir à coignières mercredi
à elancourt et jeudi à magny les hameaux
dans le même temps la décision a été
officialisée vendredi le second tour des
élections municipales devrait se tenir
le 28 juin prochain sauf avis contraire
du conseil scientifique
le gouvernement demandera un deuxième
avis quelques jours avant le scrutin
dans les yvelines environ 40 communes
doivent encore désigner leurs maires
comme attrape trois candidats sont en
position de semin
tenir pour le second tour dans la ville
voici leurs réactions collectées par
téléphone dans l'ordre de leur arrivée
au premier tour la priorité doit être
donnée à la santé des français
parfois des arbitrages du gouvernement
consiste à privilégier la reprise
économique sur la situation sanitaire et
la santé de nos concitoyens
la décision a été prise nous sommes en
ordre de bataille pour le 28 juin et je
considère aussi qu'il est nécessaire que
les services municipaux soient mobilisés
et mobilisables avec des élus légitimé
par le suffrage universel pour
accompagner les français et permettre la
reprise des activités dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
moi mon souhait c'est surtout qu' il y à
un maximum d'électeurs qui se déplace et
donc je souhaite que les toutes les
conditions soient mises en place sur la
sécurisation des bureaux de vote sur les
conditions sanitaires pour rassurer tous
les électeurs se déplacent massivement
parce que bien sûr après on choisit une
équipe municipale pour six années et je
crois que le choix qui est aujourd'hui
proposé votera piste et d'un choix
déterminant pour les années à venir et
donc j'espère que le scrutin pourra se
tenir dans les meilleurs conditions
possibles
le là tu vois ainsi alors qu il fallait
les conditions sanitaires le permettent
il a l'idée me paraît prématuré pourquoi
je dis ça c'est parce que au premier
tour et dans un certain nombre de villes
le nombre de votants était extrêmement
faible je crains que ceux qui ont évité
à venir voter au premier tour ne soient
pas rassurés dans un mois s'il n'y a pas
participation des électeurs ou n'aura
pour les responsables un mandat ou
présentant qu'une partie fait de la
population ce qui pour des municipales
du printemps bienvenus voilà mon avis à
trappes 34 % des électeurs s'étaient
déplacés aux urnes au premier tour en ce
qui concerne saint quentin en yvelines
six autres communes devront procéder à
un second tour le 28 juin prochain dans
l'actualité également ce mouvement
social chez korian les salariés de plus
de 50 maisons de retraite à travers la
france étaient en grève aujourd'hui
c'était le cas notamment à poissy comme
vous le voyez sur ces images à lille des
mignot une quinzaine de personnes
mobilisées action à l'appel de
l'intersyndicale composée de la cgt de
fo et de sud
pour demander le versement de la prime
de 1000 euros promise par la direction à
tout le personnel ainsi qu'une
revalorisation salariale
un mouvement qui coïncide avec le
lancement aujourd'hui du ségur de la
santé vaste concertation au cours de
laquelle sera abordée notamment est la
question de la rémunération des
soignants ans ait pas de crise sanitaire
les associations ont dû également
s'adapter pour continuer de fonctionner
comment font elles face à cette période
à saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'interview
est menée par marylène yapi shiloh
certaines sportives de loisirs ont dû
rester confiné d'autres à visée
humanitaire et solidaire se sont
mobilisés plus que jamais les
associations de saint quentin en
yvelines sont très nombreuses 3200 et
elles ont dû faire face à cette période
si particulière
pour en parler nous sommes en
communication avec anne charles un
bonjour bonjour alors d'être responsable
du service guichet unique vie
associative de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
donc le secteur associatif est largement
impactés par cette crise on l'a dit que
ce soit par les bénévoles qui ne peuvent
plus forcément se mobiliser les revenus
en baisse des adhérents ou des douilles
saint quentin en yvelines les soutiens
avec notamment une plateforme en ligne
comment cela se passe-t-il alors
effectivement on a mis en place un
portail dédié aux associations de saint
quentin en yvelines association en
pointe keek.fr sur ce potage jeu portail
haut on le veut vraiment site ressource
pour les associations on y dépose des
appels à projets des informations
pratiques des appels à participation
notamment effectivement pendant que ce
contexte de prises nous avons ou s'est
mobilisée pour vrai qu'en veille sur
toutes les mesures et des tiges qui
étaient les associations et on a relégué
toutes les informations sur le courtage
voilà près du bea a retrouvé toute
nature vous avez eu beaucoup de
sollicitations quelles sont leurs
inquiétudes
alors leurs inquiétudes elles portent
déjà sur la reprise d'activité à quel
moment elles vont pas reprendre leurs
activités notamment
il utilise des équipements pour moi
elles vont pouvoir accueillir leurs
bénévoles comment elles vont pouvoir
un bénéficiaire est ailleurs c'est des
années des inquiétudes aussi financière
tour voilà les renouvellements de vision
est ce qu'il va y avoir des
remboursements gestion des recettes et
du coup on envisage deux ans organise le
5 juin prochain au webinaire sur tout ce
qui est sûr là pour les aider à la
reprise
justement vous parlez de des inquiétudes
financières ils peuvent apprendre et une
baisse de subventions peut-être est-ce
que c'est prévu de les soutenir
financièrement les aider peut-être à
trouver d'autres scènes alors oui c'est
vrai que cette inquiétude
audi lieu à l'espace et forte
aujourd'hui je pense qu'elles sont
conscience que l'école est au branle un
soutien et effectivement on va aussi les
aider à trouver les financements les et
b peut-être à lancer des campagnes de
ducros funding sur financement
participatif des tracts années 2000
sénat on va essayer de les accompagner
d'autres sources de financement et puis
il ya des motifs qui existent de blanc
ce qui sont mis en place aussi dans
quatre ans alors je le dis en
introduction il ya aussi des
associations qui se sont montrés
solidaires sur lesquels on a pu se
reposer pour distribuer des blues par
exemple est ce que saint quentin en
yvelines a participé à aider ces
associations là alors effectivement il
ya des associations qui se sont se sont
mobilisés sur d'autres pour
confectionner des mâles
l'idée est relaxé y est de relayer
l'information sur le site de
l'agglomération sur les réseaux sociaux
sur les réseaux sociaux on peut le faire
connaître
en tout cas oui là on l'a dit le
territoire de ses douze communes de
saint quentin en yvelines contient un
tissu associatif qui est assez dense
elles sont trois mille deux cents qu'est
ce qui explique ce nombre ici pourquoi
pourquoi saint quentin en yvelines a
autant d'associations
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya une dynamique
associative à environ 180 associations
qui se créent chaque panier
donc c'est une association tous les deux
jours et
oui à saint-quentin-en-yvelines y ait
cette histoire de vie le fait que les
associations vraiment accompagner la
construction de l'agglomération avec un
tissu associatif qui s'est mobilisé dès
les débuts de l'agglomération quel est
le rôle d'un paul comme celui que vous
que vous vous travaillez tout simplement
d'un guichet unique pour réunir ces
associations alors on a la grande
mission du pas la centralisation des
demandes de subventions qui sont de
l'agglomération on accompagne les
associations dans leurs démarches de
demande de subventions on a un rôle de
penne 106 associatif à travers une base
de données qui répertorie l'ensemble des
associations et un annuaire qui est mis
en ligne et puis l'accompagnement aux
projets en cours de projet la mise en
relation avec les experts et
l'information l'accompagnement sur les
questions de fonctionnement de notre
section à travers ce portail est des
rendez vous comment vous voyez la suite
après cette épidémie maintenant qu'on
commence à se dégonfler petit appétit
honnêtement c'est vrai beaucoup d
associations est long et on a un rôle au
quotidien mais beaucoup plus pour
contribuer à la résilience du territoire
on voit bien que si les gens se sont
mobilisés ce qu'ils évitent pour se sont
mobilisées pour mener des actions
solidaires notamment à travers des
associations
donc oui elles ont un rôle à jouer et on
les accompagnera elle qu'elle puisse
poursuivre de bonnes conditions lors
leurs actions merci à mme charland
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle vous êtes responsable du
service bosch et unique de la vie
associative de saint quentin en yvelines
merci beaucoup une précision à présent
nous vous parlions vendredi de la visite
de roxana maracineanu opéré en yvelines
la ministre des sports s'est rendu au
centre équestre mercredi dernier pour
faire le point sur les dispositions
sanitaires qui ont permis la reprise des
activités équestres
contrairement à ce qu'affirmait notre
reportage ce ne sont pas soixante dix
mais 20 millions
d'euros qui ont été débloqués par l'état
il ya quelques semaines cette enveloppe
est dédié au centre équestre et au parc
zoologique sur tout le territoire
français
et puisqu'on évoque cette thématique ce
soir ne manquez pas le retour du 7-8
sport pour un nouveau numéro présenté
par nickel elle ni d'euros alors que la
plupart des disciplines sont à l'arrêt
bilan de la saison des clubs du
département
zoom sur les sports dont la pratique est
encore autorisée et coup d'oeil à
l'agenda des événements forcément
chambouler le cetud sport ce soir à
19h30 sur tv 78 tout en replay sur notre
application mobile où notre site
internet tv 78 points comme pour
refermer ce journal les animaux du zoo
de thoiry ont retrouvé leur public le
site yvelinois a rouvert depuis quelques
jours sa partie safari uniquement et des
mesures sanitaires ont été mises en
place par la direction pour garantir la
distanciation physique et a limité les
contacts et en ce week-end de
l'ascension les visiteurs étaient
nombreux le reportage de manon varaldo
et de mélanie poké une file d'attenté
pour accéder aux autres thoiry il a
rouvert pour des raisons sanitaires
seule la partie safari qui se fait dans
son véhicule personnel est accessible
c'était surtout de générer un parcours
fluide et de gérer le flux simplement
beau paquet soit d'embouteillages sur la
fois publique soit qui ait pas de
stationnement de rassemblement donc
c'est pique-niqué genre de choses sur
notre parking pour ces jusqu'à jusqu'à
oser jusqu'à la fin du covan on va dire
sera interdit pour profiter du
déconfinement tout en respectant la
règle des 100 km
plusieurs familles ont fait le
déplacement sur internet je cherchais ce
qui pouvait se faire parce qu'on habite
à côté de paris
donc ce qu'il pouvait se faire dans les
environs et c'était une sortie qui est
sympa pour les qui est sympa pour les
enfants parce qu'ils adorent les animaux
très bien de très agréable de pouvoir
profiter de ça pendant cette période
deux postes confinement ça fait du bien
en plus c'est dépaysant de voir autant
d'animaux les voitures se succèdent 3000
personnes par jour circulent dans le
safari à thoiry les humains sont
spectateurs des animaux qui vivent eux
en liberté il ya beaucoup de monde ça
ralentit pas mal mais les animaux sont
pas du tout sauvage donc en fait on a pu
voir des autruches carrément qui étaient
garés devant enfin positionné devant
nous donc en fait c'est pas mal on est
carrément dedans et comme on n'avance
pas on a vraiment le panorama tout le
safari du zoo de thoiry sera ouvert pour
le week-end de la pentecôte pour
déambuler de nouveau dans le zoo à pied
il faudra attendre les annonces du
gouvernement le 2 juin
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve dès demain
pour une nouvelle édition très belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]